Guten Morgen, Linus.
Guten Morgen, Tim.
Du Linus, Facebook hat gedroht, aus Europa abzuhauen. Logbuch Netzpolitik Nr. 360. Heute sozusagen der Rundumblick vom 23. September 2020.
Direkt ins Hörgebäck. Wahnsinn, wir haben extra gewartet solange, dass wir diese schöne Datum hatten für unsere Aufzeichnung.
Wieso ist das an dem Datum so schön? Ach so, die 23, meinst du? Machen wir jetzt nur noch monatlich, oder was? Ja, wir sind ein bisschen hinter unserem Zeitplan. Es haben sich verschiedene Probleme ergeben. Technischer Natur und Termine und Pipapo und Zeug.
Zumal das ja auch jetzt so ein Aspekt ist, wo man nicht sagen kann, das ist jetzt ein spezifisches Problem der deutschen Polizei derzeit. Nee, genau. Das ist halt ein generelles Problem. Also gar nicht mal nur der Polizei, aber speziell natürlich der Polizei an sich. Also das Prinzip Polizei bringt das so mit sich. Und deswegen muss das Teil sein dessen, wie eine Polizei geführt wird, sowie auch andere spezifische Bereiche des Staates, da auch andere Sensibilitäten aufweisen muss. Das betrifft genauso auch, was weiß ich, die Arbeitsagentur zum Beispiel, überhaupt soziale Dienste, die es ja auch immer, fast jeder Bereich, hat irgendwie so einen spezifischen Blick auf die Gesellschaft. Nur in dem Moment, wo es auf die Polizei kommt, reden wir nämlich auch von der konkreten Auslegung von Gesetzen und eben auch der Auslegung von angemessenen Gegenmaßnahmen gegen irgendein wahrgenommenes falsches Verhalten. Naja, und wir sehen ja nun leider sehr, dass sich so ein gewisser, ich meine, wenn die jetzt in so Nazi-Gruppen, in so WhatsApp-Gruppen da irgendwie einfach die ganze Zeit, sich einfach nur noch über Ausländer und eigentlich alle anderen, die nicht so sind wie sie, was im Prinzip auch heißt, alle, die nicht Polizisten sind, auslassen, dann läuft da einfach was schief. Dann hat man dagegen vorzugehen und dann ist es eigentlich scheißegal, ob da jetzt irgendjemand vielleicht unter Umständen unter Generalverdacht steht. Ja, dann sollten sie halt dafür sorgen, dass hier nur die Richtigen verdächtigt werden, indem man mal genau nachschaut, weil ich bin mir auch sicher, dass es vielleicht sogar auch zahlreiche, vielleicht sogar auch die Mehrheit der Polizisten, das anders sehen oder sehen wollen. Oder sich teilweise schon als Minderheit fühlen, weil sie eigentlich von so einer lautstarken anderen Minderheit so ein bisschen klein gehalten werden, wie wir das ja auch ansonsten in sozialen Gruppen sehen, in Familien sehen. Und diese Leute gehören gestärkt. Und diese Leute muss irgendwie die Möglichkeit geben werden, sowas auch anschwärzen zu können, wenn sie das sehen, ohne jetzt gleich selber wieder als Verräter dahingestellt zu werden und ausgeschlossen zu werden. Ist ja auch generell schwierig für Polizisten. Nicht, dass ich da jetzt viel Eindruck, Einblick hätte, aber das ist immer so ein bisschen meine Wahrnehmung. Polizisten tendieren dazu, auch in ihrem normalen sozialen Leben, jenseits des Berufs, viel mit Polizisten zu tun zu haben. Was auch so ein bisschen damit zu tun hat.
Dass niemand was mit Polizisten zu tun haben will.
Genau. Ja, ist doch so.
Ja, der will schon, der hat schon gerne die Polizei im Haus.
Ja, aber auch das ist ja schon schlimm genug, weil das ja sozusagen auch schon so ein grundlegendes Misstrauen zeigt. Ja, so dass du denkst, so ja, ne, weiß nicht, also mit Polizisten, da trete ich mir halt irgendeine Nazi-Truppe ein. Oder wenn es das nicht ist, halt generell so ein, ist ja gar nicht mal so, dass jetzt jeder unbedingt was zu befürchten hätte, oder dass Polizisten nicht generell auch irgendwie einen Unterschied machen können, zwischen was ist jetzt irgendwie angemessen und was ist nicht angemessen. Ist ja auch nicht so, dass sie jetzt einen ganzen Tag auf der Straße stehen und jedem gleich einen Bauschicken, der bei Rot über die Ampel geht. Aber wenn du halt bei Rot über die Ampel gehst und dabei irgendwie dem Polizeiwagen an der Ampel steht, irgendwie noch ein Finger zeigt.
Das geht auch noch. Das Problem ist, wenn du die falsche Hautfarbe hast. Also ich denke, dass ein Staat gut beraten ist, sich dieser sehr offensichtlichen und auch leicht erklärbaren Phänomene des Polizeiberufs bewusst zu sein und hier aktiv gegenzusteuern. Und was mir gerade Sorge macht, ist zum Beispiel in Mecklenburg-Vorpommern, also in Mecklenburg-Vorpommern haben sie auch festgestellt, dass die Polizei auch Nazis sind. Hatten dann in Mecklenburg-Vorpommern herausgefunden, wer hätte damit rechnen können. Und jetzt sagt halt der Innenminister Lorenz Cafier, er will rechtsextreme Strukturen innerhalb der Polizei konsequent aufarbeiten. So jetzt, was dann passieren wird, ist, und das ist, muss ich auch sagen, wahrscheinlich das andere Problem, was der Seehofer da tatsächlich auch fühlt. Wenn die da jetzt den Eindruck gewinnen, dass sie noch nicht einmal den Rückhalt ihres oberen Dienstherren haben, dann wird das sicherlich nicht zu einer Frustrationsminderung bei den Polizistinnen führen. Insofern denke ich, man muss hier von der Regierungsseite, von der Seite eines Innenministers die Verantwortung erkennen, diesen Tendenzen nachhaltig entgegenzuwirken. Und das bedeutet, den Polizeiberuf so zu gestalten, dass diesen Tendenzen entgegengewirkt wird. Und nicht erst dann, wenn man feststellt, okay, das sind jetzt voll Nazis und die haben eine WhatsApp-Gruppe, jetzt ziehen wir die aus dem Verkehr. Das, glaube ich, ist einfach auch falsches Management dieses nachvollziehbaren Problems in dem Moment, wo du sagst, du machst eine Polizei. Auf jeden Fall finde ich daher diese Nachricht sehr gut, die ich in der Zeitung Der Postillon gelesen habe. Es werden jetzt also in den nächsten Monaten bundesweit 4.000 Antifa-Mitglieder eingestellt, um ein Gegengewicht. Zu den rechtsextremen Beamten in den eigenen Reihen zu bilden. Also Herbert Reul, Innenminister von Nordrhein-Westfalen, sagte, wir versuchen lieber, die Polizei wieder in die Mitte der Gesellschaft zu schieben, indem wir gezielt Linksextremisten anwerben.
Reicht es, wenn man jetzt mit der Antifa-Family Card vorspricht?
Die kannst du jetzt in einem einmaligen Tauschangebot direkt gegen Polizeidienstausweis tauschen und du behältst deine Bonuspunkte. Du gibst aber kein Demogeld mehr, also am Wochenende aber dann halt vom Staat.
Ach so, dann zahlen die natürlich nicht, weil dann zahlt ja der Staat sozusagen.
Das ist dann weg.
Okay, dann läuft ja letztlich aufs Gleiche raus.
Läuft aufs Gleiche raus und du darfst bewaffnet hingehen.
Vermummt und mit Schild und mit alles.
Es ist wirklich einfach direkt ein ganz anderes Status-Level.
Nicht mehr mit der Straßenbahn schön im Sixpack hingefahren werden. Das läuft. Okay, es gibt Leute, die können den Eindruck bekommen, wir nehmen das Thema nicht ernst.
Ich nehme das völlig ernst.
Ja, ich auch.
So, dann haben wir eine wichtige Aufgabe der antifaschistischen Polizisten besteht darin, rechtsextreme Chat-Gruppe ihrer Kollegen zu unterwandern und dort mit linken Parolen Karl Marx, Meens und Stalin-Bildern gezielt dagegen zu halten. Im täglichen Dienst sollen immer Antifa und Nazi-Polizisten paarweise Streifen fahren und sich gegenseitig in Schach halten.
Freut sich nur, welcher ist jetzt welcher. Wie das wo ankommt, wenn du dann irgendwie auf den Weg durch die Pantine, die internationale pfeifst.
Okay, so, kommen wir zu den ernsthafteren Themen. Hackereien, Hackerei, ja, und zwar gab es vor einiger Zeit eine Schwachstelle, die haben wir auch behandelt, bei Citrix. Diese Schwachstelle wurde Shitrix genannt und eignete sich quasi zu so einer sofortigen Übernahme von Citrix-Umgebungen oder Citrix-Sessions. Und Citrix ist im Prinzip so ein Fernzugangstool bzw. eher so eine Lösung für, nicht nur einen Fernzugang, sondern direkt für so ein zentralisiertes Bereitstellen von Services.
Homeoffice heißt das jetzt, Homeoffice.
Ja, also genau, Homeoffice, Fernzugänge und so, da gibt es eben dieses Citrix.
Also was früher nur System-Administrator benutzt haben und jetzt müssen alle damit klarkommen.
Genau, irgendwann haben die System-Administrator gesagt, mach das doch mit meinem Tool. So, und in diesem Rahmen dieser Schwachstelle, also als sie bekannt wurde, wurde auch sehr dazu geraten, jetzt unglaublich dringend zu patchen und zu gucken, ob bestehende Systeme vielleicht kompromittiert wurden und das haben einige getan, einige nicht getan und die Angreifer haben, so war die Vermutung und die Vermutung scheint sich zu bestätigen. Eben einfach mal ganz schnell mit dieser Schwachstelle, wo sie wussten, da patchen jetzt bald viele, erst mal so ein Fuß in die Tür geholt und dann nachher sich um ihre erreichten Angriffsziele gekümmert. Und das scheint jetzt hier dem Uniklinikum Düsseldorf passiert zu sein, wo also eine Angreifergruppe, das sich quasi in das System reingehackt hat, das klassische, wie wir es auch schon geschildert haben in unserer Folge, in der wir mal diese Emotet-Angriffe in Ruhe auseinandergenommen haben, wo man also dann sich Domänenadministrationsrechte holt und dann eben Rechner verschlüsselt. So, das haben die im Uniklinikum Düsseldorf gemacht, 30 Server des Krankenhauses verschlüsselt und damit die Klinik weitgehend außer Betrieb gesetzt. Operationen wurden verschoben, abgesagt, Behandlungen und so weiter. Rettungswagen konnten die Klinik nicht mehr anfangen, die hatten halt keine IT mehr. Das tragische an der Geschichte ist, die hatten wohl eigentlich gedacht, sie wären in der Universität Düsseldorf und haben ihre Erpressungsnotiz dann auch an die Universität Düsseldorf aufgeschrieben und tatsächlich hat die Uni Klinik Düsseldorf dann eben geantwortet, ey Leute, ihr seid hier in der falschen Straße, ihr habt hier gerade ein Krankenhaus lahm gelegt und da geht's so nicht. Und dann haben die Angreifer tatsächlich die Verschlüsselungs-, die Entschlüsselungsmöglichkeit kostenlos bereitgestellt und haben gesagt, okay, sorry, war nicht unsere Absicht. Aber es gab eine 78-jährige Notfallpatientin, die eingeliefert werden sollte und wegen dieser IT-Schwierigkeiten nicht behandelt werden konnte in der Uni Klinik Düsseldorf. Die wurde nach Wuppertal gebracht, Nachbarstadt, und verstarb nach dem Transport. Was jetzt quasi so diskutiert wird, als potenziell das erste Opfer eines, das erste Lebendopfer eines Hacking-Angriffs zumindest im zivilen Bereich. Und das ist natürlich dann schon auch sehr tragisch, dass so etwas passiert.
Aus einer halben Stunde von der einen Klinik zur anderen.
Ja, wenn du eben eine Notfallpatientin bist, die eine besondere Behandlung benötigt. Ja, also kann ja hier, also wenn es mit, wenn es IT benötigt, dann ist es vielleicht ein CT oder MRT-Scan, um Schädel-Hirn-Trauma zu untersuchen oder was auch immer. Ja, aber diese Meldungen werden, wird so ein Krankenhaus sicherlich nicht ohne weiteres so aus.
Ja, es kann auch einfach sein, dass die komplette Notaufnahme nicht funktioniert hat und die nicht in der Lage waren, einfach Leute aufzunehmen.
Jetzt wäre ich in der, würde ich vermuten, dass ein Mensch, der mit dem Tod ringt, nicht unbedingt erstmal im Wartezimmer warten muss und mit der Behandlung gewartet wird, bis die Krankenkassenkarte ordnungsgemäß gescannt wurde. Also ich würde eher vermuten, dass da auch noch medizinische, irgendwie die medizinischen Handlungsmöglichkeiten offenbar auch noch eingeschränkt waren. Aber mehr habe ich dazu jetzt auch nicht gefunden. Muss man vielleicht auch gar nicht finden, zeigt einfach nur, wie dramatisch halt dieses, die Abhängigkeit von IT ist und eben auch die Konsequenzen von solchen Angriffen sein. Dann sind wir ja hier bei Logbuch Netzpolitik nie scheu, die Erfolge der Strafvermittlungsbehörden zu betonen und zu feiern. Wir sind ja ohnehin grundsätzlich voll des Lobes für die Strafverfolgungsbehörden. Und man hört uns ja selten über die Scherze machen. Ich mache jetzt wirklich über andere Leute Scherze, nämlich über diese Leute, die den Wall Street Market betrieben haben. Da gab es übrigens Simplicissimus, der YouTube-Kanal, der Dinge erklärt. Genau. Und mit Simplicissimus hatte ich damals viel gesprochen, weil die auch eine Folge gemacht haben über, wie der Wall Street Market auseinandergenommen wurde, also wie diese Leute verhaftet wurden, welche Obseck-Bedeutung gemacht wurden.
Kannst du noch mal sagen, was der Wall Street Market war?
Ja, das war ein Online-Drogenmarkt, der galt als einer der größten, aber die gelten ja immer als irgendwie einer der größten, und wurde von Deutschen betrieben, die unter anderem auch Server hatten im Cyberbunker. Also eine spannende Geschichte rundherum. Und wir haben uns damals, oder Simplicissimus hat sich damals, vor ein paar Monaten war das, sehr damit auseinandergesetzt, also welche Fehler hatten die gemacht, dass sie am Ende entdeckt wurden. Und das habe ich dir ein bisschen bei geholfen, das einzuordnen, nämlich auch ganz kurz in dem Video drin. So, und die hatten eben ihre Server da. Und wenn ich das jetzt richtig erinnere, man kann sich das Video nochmal anschauen, wir verlinken das in den Show Notes. Es ging im Prinzip dabei darum, dass die sich irgendwie über VPN, der eine hatte sich immer über VPN angemeldet und hatte offenbar nicht den Vortrag von Thorsten und mir geschaut, wie man sich ernsthaft vor Erkennung schützt und seine VPN-Verbindung ist eben, bei dem einen ist die VPN-Verbindung ab und zu abgebrochen und dann hat er von seiner echten IP-Adresse Pakete gesendet und bei dem anderen haben sie einfach den VPN-Anbieter überwacht, also die haben quasi den Server überwacht, die Verbindung zu dem Server und die Verbindung zu dem VPN-Anbieter und haben dann einfach immer korreliert, welcher Anschluss ist zu dem Zeitpunkt mit dem VPN verbunden und der war so klug, die VPN-Verbindung immer nur dann herzustellen, wenn er sich mit seinem Wall-Street-Marketer-Administrativ verbinden wollte. Ansonsten waren die auch noch klug genug, mit teuren Autos durchs Dorf zu fahren. Also waren alles ganz große Statiken. Sind jetzt alle, soweit ich weiß, vor Gericht oder schon verurteilt. Und jetzt geht es eben um das Aufarbeiten der im Wall-Street-Market entdeckten Daten. Denn jetzt ist es natürlich so, dieser Wall-Street-Market ist ja im Prinzip ein Forum, in dem es eben Händlerinnen gibt und Käuferinnen und die können sich direkt Nachrichten schicken, die können da Sachen anbieten. Und was ich ja auch schon öfter betont habe, ist, diese ganzen illegalen Marktplätze haben im Prinzip das gleiche Problem wie Ebay, nämlich, dass sie am Ende Kontakte zwischen Menschen herstellen, die einander nicht vertrauen können, die keinen Anlass haben, einander zu vertrauen. Und die Lösung dazu ist natürlich quasi so ein Reputation-System, wo eben du einen Anreiz hast, als Händler deinen Händlernamen beizubehalten und von jedem deiner Kunden eben eine gute Bewertung zu bekommen. Da hatten wir auch schon mal Sendungstitel, Logbuch Netzpolitik, Top Silkroader gerne wieder. Und jetzt haben die natürlich diesen Server aus dem Regal gezogen und haben Zugriff auf die Daten mit anderen Worten, die wissen jetzt, wen versus wer es da so für Anbieter gibt, wie viel die verkauft haben und was die vielleicht eben intern an Daten angegeben haben. Sorry, ich bin ja gegen eine Dose getreten. So, und die Ausbeute ist tatsächlich 179 Anbieter von Drogen und anderen illegalen Gütern, wurden mit Haftbefehlen versehen und diese Haftbefehle wurden verstreckt. Hat Europol mitgeteilt, allein in Deutschland 42 Verdächtige festgenommen, in den USA 121. Der Einsatz wurde geleitet vom Bundeskriminalamt. Weitere Festnahmen noch in Österreich, Großbritannien, Niederlanden und Schweden. Und das ist die Operation Disruptor. Also Tor, das Netzwerk, über das die Hidden Services angebildet wurden. Neun Monate Ermittlung. Im Mai 2019 war eben die Zerschlagung des Wall Street Market vorweggegangen. 1,15 Millionen Kunden konnten und mehr als 5400 Verkäufer, von denen sie jetzt immerhin 179 Anbieter gecashed haben. Und ja, kann ich nur sagen, die OBSSEQ ist das Entscheidende. Das hat nichts damit zu tun, ob der komische Marktplatz, auf dem ich dich verabrede, sich im Darknet befindet oder nicht. Es gibt Hörer, die sich hier offenbar auch mit solchen Technologien beschäftigen. Ich will da niemanden jemals zu ermutigen. Aber die berichten mir von Telegram-Gruppen, in denen der Handel jetzt stattfindet. Ich würde grundsätzlich davon abraten, so etwas zu machen.
Komm, jetzt die Shirts von Attila Hildmann.
Genau, aber wenn, dann wenigstens nicht in der Chatgruppe von Attila Hildmann. Also halte ich für unkluge Ideen, sowas zu machen, für Käuferinnen weniger unklug als für Händlerinnen. Als Händlerin wäre ich sehr vorsichtig, irgendwie mehr oder weniger muss hier ja eine Übergabe in Personen stattfinden. Und das ist immer gefährlich, wäre ich vorsichtig mit.
Pass auf, wo ihr euren Shit kauft. Erinnert mich übrigens dieses ganze detektivische Nachspüren von so Hacker-Verbindungen. Ich hatte gerade vor ein paar Tagen, ist mir irgendwie über meine Timeline dieser schöne Film, den ich noch gar nicht so richtig zu Ende geschaut hatte. Damals die alte Story von Clifford Stoll, den deutschen KGB-Hackern um Karl Koch und so, was dann später zu diesem Buch des Kokoksei führte, weil dieser Clifford Stoll, der so ein Wissenschaftler war an dieser Uni, wo die sich irgendwie angehabt haben.
Der die aus seinen Systemen rausgepult hat, ne?
Genau, und da gibt es einen schönen Film, den verlinken wir auch, wo er so seine akribische Tätigkeit und seine ganzen Vorgehensweisen, wie er unter den damaligen Bedingungen herausgefunden hat, wo die denn herkommen und wie die dann ermittelt werden konnten, wie das dann so dargelegt ist. Und das ist doch eine sehr schönige Geschichte, der Clifford Stoll ist auch ein lustiger Typ, muss man sagen, ist irgendwie auch immer noch im Internet präsent. Ja, und da kann man mal ein Gefühl dafür bekommen, wie das so in den 80er-Jahren abgelaufen ist. Aber es hat sich irgendwie auch so viel nicht dran geändert, so. Es gibt immer irgendwelche Spuren, die man hinterlässt.
Ja, ähm, ich äußere mich da wenig zu, ich hab da ja auch beruflich mit zu tun. Weiß nicht, ob das noch immer so viel Spaß macht, wie bei Clifford Stoll.
Vielleicht macht es dich Spaß, für Leute, um das jetzt mal so nachzuvollziehen, weißt du? Ja, ich glaube, das ist eine ganz interessante, diese direktivische Leistung ist auf jeden Fall eine ganz interessante.
Ja, auf jeden Fall, also man kann da sehr akribisch vorgehen und deswegen betonen und loben wir das ja auch bei der Polizei, weil das ist ja die gleiche Polizei, deren verantwortliche Innenminister und irgendwie Dienststellenleiter und Amtleiter und so weiter und LKA-Leiter die ganze Zeit behaupten, man wäre jetzt hier, man wäre hier irgendwie blind und da muss man doch wirklich sagen, da würdigen die die Arbeit der Kolleginnen und Kollegen nicht. So, dann bleiben wir noch ganz kurz bei den Hackern. Es beginnt der Prozess gegen diesen Orbit gerade. Das ist der Teenager, der Anfang letzten Jahres Aufsehen erregte, weil er die persönlichen Daten von vielen Prominenten und Politikerinnen veröffentlicht hat.
Auf Twitter.
Genau, über Twitter, also auf verschiedenen, ja wie heißen die denn, Shared-Hosting-Plattformen, hier so den Rapid-Share-Nachfolgern und so. Da war das alles veröffentlicht und hat dann diesen Adventskalender da gemacht. Und dann irgendwann hat er am Ende seines Adventskalenders alles geleakt und dann war großes Thema. Und wir haben da damals auch hier ausführlich zugesprochen und dann war ja die große Frage, wir haben das wie gesagt Anfang letzten Jahres ausführlich besprochen, wo hat er die Daten her? Und stellt sich raus, der hat ja von wheeliginfo.com einfach runtergeladen. Dieser Service, von dem wir auch gesprochen haben, der vor ein paar Monaten dann auch eingestellt wurde. Sieht danach aus, dass der irgendwie nach Jugendstrafrecht eine relativ milde Strafe bekommt. Das ist Aufgabe der Richterin, das zu beurteilen. Aber zumindest die eine Hypothese hält sich sehr stark, die ich damals auch von Anfang an vertreten habe, dass das eher eine Frage der Akribie war, als eine Frage des Könnens bei dem jungen Mann. Also eher eine Frage von Akribie und krimineller Energie als oder Geltungsdrang, als jetzt irgendwie dass der irgendwie besondere Fähigkeiten gehabt hätte. Wer auch keine besonderen Fähigkeiten hat, ist ja die Schufa. Und die müssen ja trotzdem jeweils neue Geschäftsmodelle entwickeln. Und die Schufa plant jetzt eine neue Form von Datenbank für ihre Kundinnen und Kunden anzubieten. Und zwar stellen sie fest, dass es eine Nachfrage gibt der Energieversorger, also der Strom- und Gasanbieter, nach eventuell einer Datenbank, in der Menschen verzeichnet werden, die regelmäßig den Anbieter wechseln. Und zwar ist es ja so, dass die sehr häufig so Log-Angebote haben. Die setzen ja im Prinzip darauf, dass sie dich einmal mit einem günstigen Angebot ködern und dann kriegst du irgendeinen Brief, den du ignorierst, in dem gesagt wird, übrigens Kilowattstundenpreis erhöhen, blablabla, pipapo. Und dann hast du irgendwie so einen Stromanbieter, bis du es vergessen hast. Übrigens ähnlich wie ich, ich glaube, ich habe auch seit vielen Jahren einen gleichen Stromanbieter. Und wenn ich einen Brief von dem kriege, erinnere ich mich auch immer, wer das ist. Selbstverständlich. Solar und Wind. Kommt natürlich trotzdem hier aus dem Atomkraftwerk nebenan, aber mit dem Geld investieren die ja dann rein. Langer Rede, kurzer Sinn. Es wäre ja total ärgerlich, wenn es Menschen gäbe, die aus reiner Boshaftigkeit, das sind ja schlechte Menschen, die aus reiner Boshaftigkeit einfach mal jedes Jahr gucken, was der günstigste Angebot ist, das nehme ich. Solche Menschen wollen wir nicht. Solche Menschen wollen wir nicht in unserer Gesellschaft. Da müssen wir eine Datenbank haben und die möchte die Schufa jetzt bauen, um den Unternehmen es zu ermöglichen, systematisch Kunden abzulehnen, die häufig wechseln und deshalb für die Firmen wirtschaftlich unattraktiv sind, weil die sich die günstigen Preise suchen und sich nicht dauerhaft an sie binden. Das finde ich schon bernstark, diese Bestrebungen.
Ja, ich meine, so war jetzt freie Marktwirtschaft nicht gemeint.
Echt? Du kommst nur zu uns, wenn wir mal die günstigsten sind.
Seit wann regelt das der Markt?
Also das wird jetzt noch irgendwie in den Datenschutzkonferenzen und so diskutiert. Die Landesdatenschutzbeauftragten halten sich da jetzt erst mal ein bisschen zurück. Aber ich denke, hier wird man sich schon die Frage gefallen lassen, ob das vom Datenschutzrecht überhaupt gedeckt ist, dass du jetzt unterschreibst, nehmt mich meine Datenbank auf, wenn ich das letzte Mal meinen Stromanbieter gekündigt habe. Wenn ihr demnächst die Preise erhöht und jemand anderes günstiger ist, ich nicht nachher hier die Prinzipien des Marktes gegen euch anwende und einfach mir mal ein günstigeres Angebot suche.
Das finde ich schon, wenn ihr das dürft. Wie viele machen das? Es gibt ja jetzt mittlerweile diese sogenannten Vergleichsplattformen, die einem so einen Wechsel ja dann auch relativ leicht machen.
Klar, weil die ja auch die Provisionen abstreichen.
Genau, und da sind dann vielleicht auch diese Provisionen so ein bisschen das Problem, also schwierig, also letzten Endes ist das Problem ja die Art und Weise, wie die Unternehmen ihre Kunden auch versuchen zu kriegen über solche Angebote und über solche Plattformen. Gut, bei Strom kann ich das verstehen, auch bei im Telekommunikationsmarkt ist das ja auch immer wieder ein Thema, oder Gas generell, also Energie, Netz, alles was so auf den ersten Blick die Dienstleistung ja immer gleich ist. Du kannst dich ja als Stromanbieter, du lieferst ja keinen geileren Strom oder besseres Wasser.
Könnten sie ja auch mal machen. Bei uns gibt es 260 Volt.
Das würde ich jetzt nicht unbedingt als geileren Strom bezeichnen.
Mit We-Power.
Ja, aber das ist natürlich schon ein Problem, weil klar, wir machen das irgendwie, wir gehen da so nach einem idealistischen Vorgang und schauen vielleicht jetzt nicht auf das letzte Cent. So, es ist uns dann irgendwie egal, ob der Strom irgendwie 31 oder 32 Cent pro Kilowatt spürt.
So teuer ist der bei dir? Weiß ich gar nicht, wie die aktuellen Preise sind.
Hast du so einen Tipp, wo es gerade billiger ist?
Ich gucke mal hier, hier gibt es eine Empfehlung, also ich weiß nicht, wie oft du den schon gewechselt hast, vielleicht nehmen die nicht noch.
Ich bin eigentlich ein sehr treuer Kunde. Ich glaube nicht, dass ich jetzt irgendwie in der Schufa-Bank landen werde, aber man weiß das schon so ganz genau.
Vor allem bist du ja bei deinem O2 dann ein sehr treuer Kunde entgegen aller Geißelungen.
Ja, die schaffen es irgendwie am Ende immer wieder, so einen Kniff freizuschalten, wo ich sage, okay, war jetzt ganz praktisch.
Also das ist auf jeden Fall eine, also die Schufa argumentiert ihre Daseinsberechtigung daher, dass sie den Leuten helfen, sich zu, die Leute davor schützen, sich zu überschulden. Aber die Schufa hat mir nicht dabei zu helfen, mich zu übersparen beim Strom. Das ist einfach nicht in Ordnung, eine derartige Kartei zu führen. Und ich denke, das wird ein gefundenes Fressen für eine Klage, oder?
Tja, denke ich auch. Also das geht nicht. Das geht nicht.
Ich wechsle jetzt erst den Stromanbieter.
Echt? Ich gucke gerade, was ich...
Wobei lieber nicht während der Sendung. Wer weiß? Das soll ja so schnell gehen heutzutage, nicht, dass hier zwischendurch kurz der Strom ausfällt. Also stellt immer vor, Stromanbieter wechseln wäre so scheiße, wie Internetanbieter wechseln. Jaja, wir kommen. Heute Nachmittag kommen wir. Vor 13 Uhr kommen wir dann. Also wir waren um 17 Uhr da, da war ja bei Ihnen brannte kein Licht. Da sind wir wiedergegangen.
23,32 Cent bis 25 Cent, billiger als ich dachte.
Kann man direkt mehr... Hier steht das gar nicht bei meinem Anbieter.
Also da kommt ja natürlich immer noch der Grundpreis dazu. Von daher ist das dann auch relativ. Da müsste ich mal so einen effektiven Kilowattstundenbetrag ausrechnen.
Ja, ich weiß es auch nicht. Aber ich muss mal ein Post-Satzzahl eingeben. Ne, ne. Also, die letzte Meldung habe ich gar nicht mehr richtig vorbereitet. Diese TikTok-WeChat-Sache hat sich irgendwie weiter verschärft, dann aber doch nicht mehr. Dann hat Trump gesagt, jetzt hier Sonntag machen wir das alles aus. Dann hat irgendeine Richterin gesagt, sei ein bisschen verrückt, lass das sein. Und es sieht jetzt im Moment danach aus, dass Oracle das irgendwie diesen Handel vollziehen möchte, mit TikTok eine US-amerikanisch gehandelte Entität zu schaffen. Und gleichzeitig zieht China aber jetzt irgendwie Schutzmöglichkeiten ein, um da in dieser Übernahme sich vor einem Abfluss des Intellectual Property, also der Algorithmen zu schützen. Das ist also insgesamt ist das alles, ich kann es nur als eine absolute Shitshow bezeichnen, was da passiert. Und deswegen möchte ich empfehlen, hat uns auch, wurden wir auch durch einen Hörer darauf hingewiesen. Ich habe die Mail leider jetzt nicht mehr vorliegen, dass es jetzt auf Netflix eine schöne Doku mit dem Namen The Social Dilemma gibt. Wahrscheinlich heißt sie auf Deutsch anders. Und da geht es um den gesellschaftlichen, den negativen gesellschaftlichen Einfluss von sozialen Netzwerken im weitesten Sinne, aber auch insbesondere der Techniken, die sie verwenden, um unsere Aufmerksamkeit zu erlangen. Bekannte Personen, die in diesem Film auftreten, sind einmal Christopher Wiley. Das ist der Autor des Buches Mindfuck, der im Prinzip diesen ganzen Cambridge Analytica-Skandal damals ins Rollen brachte, mit seinen Aussagen dazu. Jéran Lanier, der ja mit etwas zugespitzten Aussagen schon länger von sich reden macht, in dieser Doku mir aber jetzt nicht besonders negativ aufgefallen ist. Und Tristan Harris, der bei Google früher war und inzwischen seine eigene Organisation hat, jetzt fände ich den Namen nicht mehr genau ein, aber die sich im Prinzip, ich glaube Responsible Tech oder sowas heißen. Mir fällt es jetzt leider gerade nicht mehr ein, muss man ganz kurz in meinen Mails schauen, weil wir haben, wir waren damals schon ein bisschen mit ihm in Kontakt und hatten auch gehofft, ihn beim Camp zu haben. Humane Tech heißen die. Hatten Hoffnung, den auch beim Camp zu haben mit dem Vortrag. Das hat dann aber sehr kurzfristig dann leider Donnig hingehauen. Und der setzt sich jetzt gar nicht unbedingt damit auseinander, was jetzt hier die Manipulationsmacht der sozialen Medien ist, sondern welche psychologischen Mechanismen die benutzen, um dich im Prinzip süchtig nach ihrem Service zu machen. Also die Notifications, die du so kriegst und die Belohnungen, oder dass das Ding dich auffordert. Sowieso hat Hallo gesagt, reagiere jetzt darauf. Oder dass zum Beispiel die Notification eben, solange sie nur auf deinem Bildschirm ist, dass someone tagged you in a photo und nicht das Foto dabei ist, damit du halt noch die App öffnest, wieder damit interagierst und so weiter. Die Doku ist, ja, ist jetzt blöd zu sagen, dass für mich da jetzt nichts großartig neu drin war, weil ich mich aber mit diesem Thema seit vielen Jahren auseinandersetze. Auf jeden Fall ist es in dieser Doku nochmal sehr schön aufgearbeitet und regt zu Reflektionen darüber an und ich habe dann auch nochmal, auch wenn am Ende die Empfehlungen der in dieser Doku zur Sprache kommenden Expertinnen relativ mager sind, habe ich dann trotzdem auch mal ein bisschen meine Notifications hier in meinem mobilen Betriebssystem nochmal neu angepasst darauf, was ich denn wirklich brauche. Also kann man auf jeden Fall schauen und kann man auch empfehlen.
Also du fährst dein Engagement sozusagen runter mit den Plattformen?
Ja, nicht, dass ich damit in irgendeiner Schufa-Datenbank lande als schlechter Klicker.
Ich wollte schon sagen, also das geht dann auf dein Social Scoring.
Ja, aber das habe ich ohnehin schon immer bemüht. Wer mir E-Mails schreibt, weiß, dass da längere Zeit auf Antwort gewartet wird. Wer versucht, mich irgendwie über Twitter zu erreichen oder so, weiß, dass ich da in der Regel... Also das ist alles nicht mit Notifikationen versehen.
Du ziehst dich also raus aus dem Netz?
Nein, ich bin ja immer noch drin. Es zieht mich ja zu den Menschen. Aber es ist auf jeden Fall nicht so schlecht, sich dieser Phänomene auf jeden Fall bewusst zu werden.
Falls es sich doch irgendwann wieder zum Internet ziehen sollte, Linus, braucht man ja auch einen Anschluss. Das ist ja schon klar. Und mit dem Anschluss ist es ja in Deutschland ein bisschen schwierig. Also man hat ja gedacht, okay, jetzt hat sich der Osten, dem Westen angeschlossen, das reicht jetzt auch erstmal mit Anschluss. Mehr Anschluss brauchst du nicht. Und erst heute wird uns ja auch so klar, was uns eigentlich alles so verloren gegangen ist. Damals unter anderem auch viele interessante Glasfaserprojekte. Also das ist wirklich so absolut. Ja, Opal, also das sogenannte Opal-Ghetto.
Die optische Anschlussleitung.
Hatte einen schlechten Ruf, aber nur weil es nicht überall war. Und weil es da nicht weitergebaut wurde, weil halt alle auf dieses billige DSL aus den USA gesetzt haben. Anstatt zu sagen so, nö, wir ziehen das jetzt mal durch. Weil im Prinzip war ja die deutsche Bundespost Ende der 80er Jahre drauf und dran, Deutschland mit einer Glasfaserinfrastruktur zu versorgen. Und hätten sie das mal weiter gemacht. Und ja, das Opal-Ghetto ist dann halt so ein bisschen in einen schlechten Ruf gekommen. Aber das lag ja nicht an der optischen Anschlussleitung, sondern das liegt nur daran, dass dich dann keiner mehr an die optische Anschlussleitung anschließen wollte. Und jetzt haben wir dann eben die letzten Jahrzehnte mit diesem ganzen Kupferanschluss weiter verbracht, aus dem dann halt noch mal irgendwie eine Frequenz nach der anderen rausgequetscht wurde. Und hier nochmal ein Megabit und da nochmal. Und was auch immer gerade da so aus diesem dünnen Draht noch gerade so rausgedrückt werden konnte, war dann immer so der aktuelle Bandbreiten-Hype. Ja, jetzt noch ein Megabit mehr und noch ein Megabit mehr. Und wir hatten das Thema jetzt ja auch schon irgendwie so einige Male. Und irgendwie hat das ja auch so als sedierender Wirkstoff ganz lange funktioniert. Also Leute haben ja gesagt, so ja, ich brauche ja auch nicht mehr und was soll ich denn? Und jetzt habe ich schon 100 Megabit und wann nutze ich denn das schon mal und so? Und ja gut, das mag ja durchaus sein, dass Leute über Anschlüsse verfügen, die sie nicht ausnutzen. Aber das ist ja auch kein Grund, anderen Leuten, die sie sehr wohl ausnutzen, die dann trotzdem zur Verfügung zu stellen, weil die da was mit anfangen können. Dein Auto fährt wahrscheinlich auch schneller als du irgendwie normalerweise fährst, aber es gibt halt manchmal auch...
Ich habe gar kein Auto.
Du hast kein Auto. Ich habe gar kein Internet anschlossen. Naja, auf jeden Fall scheint sich das jetzt aber so langsam mal rumgesprochen zu haben, dass das eine Scheißidee war. Und tatsächlich hat der Bundestag jetzt ein neues Gesetz beschlossen, was versucht, gleich mit mehreren Problemen so ein bisschen ein Ende zu finden, nämlich dieses Problem, dass du als, selbst wenn du Eigentümer in einem Haus bist, also sag mal, dir gehört eine Wohnung innerhalb eines Häuserkomplexes, dass du jederzeit von dieser Eigentümerversammlung überstimmt werden konntest, wenn du eigentlich sinnvolle Sachen gefordert hast. Das betrifft zum Beispiel eben das Verliegen von Glasfaser, aber auch so andere Sachen wie zum Beispiel Barrierefreiheit oder eben jetzt auch ganz aktuell der Anschluss eines Ladeports in der Garage. Wenn du jetzt in so einem Eigentumskluster wohnst, wo alle so ihre Wohnung haben, dann hast du da so Shared-Garagen. Und dann, ja, ich will mir aber jetzt hier Elektroauto kaufen und wie wär's denn mal mit einer Steckdose, sagen die anderen ja, alles viel zu teuer. Jetzt gibt es auf jeden Fall dieses neue Gesetz. Und dieses Gesetz verhindert eben für diese Fälle, dass du überstimmt werden kannst. Mit anderen Worten, wenn ein Eigentümer der Meinung ist, das hat jetzt mal zu sein, dann können die anderen dem nichts mehr entgegensetzen. Das ist zumindest der Objective, das Ziel des Gesetzesentwurf zur Förderung der Elektromobilität und zur Modernisierung des Wohneigentumsgesetzes. Und ja, es soll also hier jedem Wohnungseigentümer ermöglicht werden, bauliche Veränderungen durchzusetzen, die dem Gebrauch durch Menschen mit Behinderung, dem Laden elektrisch betriebener Fahrzeuge, dem Einbruchschutz und dem Glasfaseranschluss dienen. Das sind wir also jetzt. Glasfaseranschluss hat jetzt dieselbe Bedeutung wie Auto betanken oder Behinderungsprobleme aufzulösen. Wow, klingt erstmal ganz gut. Ist allerdings, ich habe mal kurz in den Text reingeschaut, etwas schwammig formuliert. Zum Beispiel gibt es da so eine Formulierung, ich weiß jetzt nicht, ob das die letztlich definierende ist, aber es ist zum Beispiel bauliche Veränderungen dienen dem Anschluss an ein solches Netz, wenn sie dem Wohnungseigentümer in seinem Sondereigentum die Nutzung eines Telekommunikationsnetzes eröffnen, das entweder komplett aus Glasfaserkomponenten zumindest bis zum Verteilerpunkt am Ort der Nutzung besteht. Da würde ich sagen, okay, Ort der Nutzung zumindest, also nehme ich, weil der Ort der Nutzung ist ja bei mir zu Hause, also da will ich dann Glasfaser auch haben. Jetzt kommt aber wieder so ein oder, oder, dass zu üblichen Spitzenlastzeiten eine ähnliche Netzleistung in Bezug auf die verfügbare Downlink- und Ablenkbandbreite, Ausfallsicherheit, fehlerbezogene Parameter, Latenz und Latenzschwankungen bieten kann.
Das verstehe ich nicht. Den Satz, das würde ich in den Antrag an die Eigentümerversammlung einfach verspeisen.
Also was sie hier sagen ist, eigentlich muss es Glasfaser sein, sollte es aber irgendwie was geben, die selben Anforderungen...
Dann können wir auch eine Katastrophenwarn-App machen, die nicht ganz so gut funktioniert, aber... und eine Sirene.
Ja gut, ich meine, das will ich erst mal sehen, über welchen anderen Weg du quasi dieselbe Latenz und Latenzschwankungen hinbekommst. Was ich hier zum Beispiel mal geltend machen würde, ist, sag mal mal, du legst Glasfaser nicht in die Wohnung, sondern du legst es in so einen Verteilerpunkt im Haus und dann ist da auch ein ordentlicher Internet-Switch dran, der da irgendwie mit, weißt du, mit 10 Gigabit das durchs Haus brät. Da würde ich dann mitgehen. Dann ist das sozusagen, da ist die Downlink- und Uplink-Bandbreite auch gesichert und die Latenz und die Latenzschwankungen. Also da ist dann auch nicht mehr so viel rauszuholen. Aber was hier im Wesentlichen doch fallen sollte durch diese Formulierung, ist halt der Anschluss über Kupfer. Denn, und das machen sich ja auch viele Leute nicht klar, die sagen, naja wieso, hier ich hab doch meinen Kabelanschluss bei Kabel Deutschland und die versprechen mir hier irgendwie ein Megabit und guck mal, ich hab ja hier auch so und so viel Download. Ja, mag sein, kann alles hinhauen. Nur wenn man sich das eben mal wirklich auf Netzebene anschaut, also wenn man mal genau hinschauen würde, wie viele Fehler und Retransmissions man hat, ja, also wie lange man nicht mal ein Paket dann doch braucht, bis es wirklich kommt. Am Ende magst du zwar ordentliche Download-Zeiten haben und es mag für dich auch vielleicht das primäre, der primäre Nutzen einer schnellen Internetverbindung sein, dass du einen schnellen Download hast. Aber spätestens zu Corona haben wir ja auch gelernt, naja so Latenz ist jetzt auch nicht so ganz unwichtig. Videokonferenzen, Audiokonferenzen etc. leben auch davon, dass man sich irgendwie ja so schnell unterbrechen kann, dass es gar nicht erst so richtig zu einer Unterbrechung führt, sondern man sich darüber abstimmt, aber wenn irgendwie alles mit einer Sekunde Verzögerung passiert, dann wird es halt richtig eklig. Und das sind halt alles so Dinge. Es wird halt nie besser als das Medium, auf dem du aufsetzt und wenn schon dein Kupferkabel, das gilt ja letztlich auch für einen normalen Kabelanschluss oft, wenn das eben schon solche Fehler erzeugt und damit eben auch solche Latenzen erzeugt, dann kann es darüber nicht besser werden. Naja, also angeblich ist der Glasfaserinteressenverband VATM noch nicht so ganz so glücklich, ob dieser schwammigen Formulierung oder auch vielleicht noch irgendeine andere Formulierung, die ich nicht gefunden habe, aber immerhin gibt es jetzt sowas. Wird ja langsam was. Also ich glaube, jetzt haben sie das langsam verstanden. Das war ja auch einfach zu peinlich. Wobei, was sie nicht verstanden haben, das muss man an dieser Stelle vielleicht auch noch mal genau sagen, wir haben in Deutschland immer noch nicht, und das zeichnet sich meiner Meinung nach auch nicht ab, dass wir das bekommen werden, noch nicht den richtigen Ansatz, wie Telekommunikationsnetze aufgebaut werden sollen. Dieses ganze Ding mit Glasfaser ist jetzt eigentlich nur die nächste Augenwischerei auf die Welt gekommen, weil jetzt heißt es ja, naja, wenn die Telekom dir einen Glasfaseranschluss zu Hause hinlegt, dann ist doch alles super, was willst du denn eigentlich? Ja gut, wenn die Telekom mir dann einen ordentlichen Tarif macht und da irgendwie schnelle Daten rausfallen, meinetwegen. Aber ich will ja auch meinen Anbieter mal wechseln können, alle 20 Minuten, damit ich einen schönen Eintrag bei der Schufa kriege. Und dafür haben wir einfach nicht das richtige System, denn derzeit wird ja im Prinzip von privaten Firmen auf Antrag irgendwo im Land Infrastruktur verbuddelt. Und je nachdem, wie die sich dann mit den Hauseigentümern einigen können, landet halt der eine Anbieter oder der andere Anbieter da. Das haben wir bei Kabelfernsehen schon gesehen und das ist jetzt im Prinzip bei diesen ganzen Glasfaseranschlüssen genau das selbe Ding. Weil es wirft immer wieder Kosten auf. Glasfaseranschluss am Haus ist sozusagen auch noch nicht das Ende vom Lied. Du willst es ja eigentlich to the home haben, also in die Wohnung haben. Das bedeutet, dass Glasfaserleitungen auch innerhalb des Hauses verlegt werden müssen. Das ist aber jetzt nicht so eine Technologie wie Strom oder Wasser, wo du einfach irgendeinen Installateur nehmen kannst und dann ist es richtig. Sondern da kann eben auch noch sehr viel falsch gemacht werden. Deswegen haben wir da nicht den Standard. Dann kommen halt die Firmen und sagen, naja, nee, dann wollen wir das aber auch alles selber machen, damit es auch funktioniert, damit wir da keinen Ärger haben. Was ich auch so ein bisschen verstehen kann. Aber irgendwo ist die Sache nicht rund, weil wir nicht mit Helmut Kohl gegangen sind. Ist ja überhaupt klar, dass Helmut Kohl eigentlich der größte Visionär der Telekommunikation ist und er wusste es selber nicht. Ja, er sprach ja mal von der Datenautobahn und ganz Deutschland hat sich irgendwie den Bauch gehalten. Und ich muss sagen...
Ungefähr die Abdeckung haben wir inzwischen aber auch erreicht.
Die Abdeckung, du meinst welche?
Von dem Autobahnnetz, ja.
Ja, und vor allem, wenn man sich mal anschaut, wie ist denn die Autobahn organisiert? Die Autobahn ist vom Staat bezahlt, vom Staat betrieben. Jeder hat da freien Zugang drauf. Du kannst an jeder Ausfahrt und Abfahrt runterfahren. Okay, du hast jetzt Maut und so. Okay, gut, anderer Aspekt. Aber es ist eine Infrastruktur, die allen zur Verfügung steht und auf der sich dann eben Business und privates Leben einfach abspielen kann. Und wo jeder im Prinzip Dienstleistungen darauf anbieten kann. Und übertragen auf eine Telekommunikation müssten wir halt eigentlich ein System haben, wo Glasfasern, die in Häuser gehen, jedem Zugang bieten müssen. Das müssen eigentlich reine, wie man so schön sagt, Darkfibers sein, also unbeleuchtet. Sprich, das Kabel liegt da, also die Faser liegt da, aber mit wem sie sich verbindet im ersten Schritt, bleibt offen. Du kennst die Beispiele aus Schweden und anderen nordischen Ländern, und überhaupt vielen anderen Ländern, die nicht in Deutschland sind. Dann gehst du halt in so eine Wohnung rein und hast diesen Anschluss und steckst dich da irgendwie mit Ethernet rein. Also dein Glasfaser kommt halt irgendwie an, dein Übergabepunkt ist so ein Ethernet, dann steckst du dich da rein oder hast vielleicht gleich so ein WLAN, wie auch immer. Und die erste Seite, die du aufrufst, ist halt quasi die Seite von deinem Gerät. Und das sagt dann, hallo, ich bin's, dein Anschluss an das Internet. Welchen Provider hättens denn gern? Und dann hast du da eine Liste mit irgendwie, ja hättest du gerne Telekom, hättest du gerne O2, hättest du gerne hier deinen lokalen Hacker-Provider, Preise hier. Und dann sagst du ja, ich nehm gern den und dann hast du Internet. So einfach kann es sein. Und so einfach müsste es meiner Meinung nach auch sein. Und das ist irgendwie so eine Zukunft, von der ich noch nicht weiß, ob wir auf die zurollen. Aber eigentlich müsste die Gesetzesinitiative in Deutschland auf sowas hinauslaufen. Dass wir da einfach gute Provider haben können, dass man die jederzeit wechseln kann, wenn die keine ordentliche Infrastruktur hinkriegen, wenn die mit ihrem IPv6 Scheiße machen, wenn ihr DNS-Server Scheiße läuft, wenn die irgendwelche blöden Sperren falsch umsetzen, wenn die einfach kacke sind, oder wenn die einfach keinen ordentlichen Peerings haben zu anderen Provider, dann wechselst du einfach deinen Provider. Und zwar nicht nach 24 Monaten, wenn dein Vertrag ausläuft, sondern halt gleich Montag.
So wollen wir das, so wollen wir das, Tim.
So wollen wir das haben. Wünscht ihr was mit Logbuch Netzpolitik?
Genau, wir kämpfen für euer Fiber to the Home, to the Bettkante. Ja, ich finde das aber sehr schön, dass Helmut Kohl mit der Datenautobahn das bessere Internet visioniert hatte. Aber keiner hat zugehört. Alle haben gelacht, genauso wie wenn du dir schnell das Netz wünschst. Helmut und Helmut hätten das damals geklärt für uns.
Wir sind einfach verkannt. Die Geschichte ist an uns vorbeigegangen.
Da hättest du noch einige Mauern im Internet niedergerissen.
Ich sag dir, was ich noch alles vereinigt hätte.
Okay, ich glaube, damit sind wir am Ende der Sendung. Ich würde sagen, ich nehme jetzt die Hilti und bohre hier unten schon mal einen Stromanschluss. Für mein Elektroauto kann mir ja keiner mehr verbieten. Dann wechsle ich den Stromanbieter. Und wenn ich schon dabei bin, kann ich eigentlich direkt weiterbohren für die Faser.
So sieht es aus.
Also ich meine, anders wird das hier nichts mehr. Wir müssen tatsächlich auch erkennen, um jetzt mal bei dem Historieverbleib gleich zu bleiben, dass wir hier tatsächlich die digitalen Trümmerfrauen der Republik sind und hier was aufbauen müssen.
Aber nicht zu groß das Loch machen, weil das muss ja auch dem Einbruchschutz gerecht werden.
Ich mache das direkt accessible, ich mache da direkt ein barrierefreies Loch. Okay, damit sind wir am Ende der Sendung.
Willst du noch Danke sagen?
Ich würde gerne danken, ja. Und zwar habe ich eine Reihe an Leuten, denen mein besonderer Dank gilt. Das ist insbesondere Rüdiger und Nils und Benjamin und Rumo und natürlich Jonas, Lukas, Tobias und Christian. Vielen herzlichen Dank!
Und vielen Dank an alle regelmäßigen Unterstützer von Logbuch Netzpolitik und der Meta-Ebene im Allgemeinen. Und macht das auch bitte weiterhin, hilft auf jeden Fall. Und damit entlassen wir euch in diese Woche. Mal gucken, vielleicht kriegen wir unsere zeitlichen Ausrutscher auch wieder aufgeholt.
Ciao.